el despliegue de tropas rusas en solo ti
a 25 km de ucrania fue captado por la
compañía de tecnología satelital
estadounidense maksar el domingo la
mayoría del batallón se había ido aquí
se le puede ver desplazándose hacia el
sur en dirección a ucrania además de las
pruebas de movimientos como éste maksar
también ha publicado imágenes de nuevos
despliegues militares a lo largo de la
semana pasada al menos 50 helicópteros
llegaron al aeródromo del ida en el
noroeste de belarús y un nuevo
contingente con helicópteros tanques y
otros vehículos blindados fue
fotografiado en la pista rusa de miller
ovo a 16 kilómetros de ucrania otros
equipamientos fueron enviados más al
norte cerca de la localidad de vall week
y a 15 km del territorio ucraniano y más
unidades llegaron al noroeste de la
ciudad de bélgorod los analistas de
maksar aseguran que todo indica un nuevo
nivel de disposición de las 150.000
tropas rusas que rodean ucrania mientras
que los bombardeos se han intensificado
en el frente que separa a las fuerzas
ucranianas ya los epa
eeuu asegura que rusia busca fabricar un
pretexto para invadir basándose en un
ataque diseñado para mostrar a ucrania
como el responsable mientras moscú acusa
a washington de difundir propaganda
bélica para provocar la ofensiva de
ucrania